kado distant
[Applause]
hey bozo are you ready for my stylish
moves my spinners razor-sharp
when it spins a minute
[Applause]
1,000 SPF impossible
[Music]
[Applause]
he's the perfect spinner heartless
soulless I paid a lot to me and I'm
gonna win it all back once we take the
grand prize
I've sacrificed a lot to get here and
now if I have this figured out this
competition is all about speed and I've
been practicing
why is the crowd booing dabbing it's not
cool anymore this is the last opponent
standing between me and $100 in prize
money he doesn't stand a chance
on fire I want to win I'm gonna need to
focus it all started two years ago after
the accident they said my little brother
would never walk again
but have I had a hundred dogs I could
buy him some new bones
wait a minute
I've seen it before
[Music]
[Applause]
and now you'll finally know the truth
the one who ruined your brother's life
was me it was you there's no way I can
win not with this dinner but I still
have one more trick up my sleeve
professor Okinawa made me promise to
destroy it I'm gonna have to break that
promise these psycho crystals could
drive me insane it's my only shot
Redemption
[Music]
I couldn't get a measure on it he's not
the spectrum
[Music]
[Music]
we have a new champion
brother I'm getting you
[Music]
[Music]